-Now, here's how
this game's gonna work, okay?
Justin, you're gonna ask us
a question about yourself.
Jessica and I
will write down our answers,
and then you'll reveal
the correct answer,
and we'll see which one of us
knows you better.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There are your questions
right there.
You have your questions
written down.
Justin, let's see
the first question.
"Who's my all-time
favorite rapper?"
-Ooh.
-Great question.
-Trick question.
-Oh, trick --
There's two, actually.
-Oh, okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Favorite rapper?
Is a trick question?
There's two of them?
So, there's one rapper
that's gone under different
names maybe?
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
♪♪
All right.
[ Both laugh ]
Jess, what did you write down?
-Mase and Andre 3000.
-Mase and Andre 3000?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just put Run DMC.
I didn't understand.
But I know there's three --
there's three.
But there's two --
Whoa!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How'd you know that?
Of course you'd know that.
-Of course I know this.
-All right, let's get
to the next question...
-Why don't you know this?
-...the ones
that your best buddy knows.
[ Laughter ]
All right, come on.
I got to get one of these.
Okay.
"What's my go-to cocktail?"
Come on.
-Oh.
Okay.
Tricky.
Some options here.
♪♪
-It's one of two things.
-Agreed.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Oh, no.
Did you look and that's not it?
Oh, God.
-Are you confident?
-I'm kind of.
One, two...
-Three.
-...three, show.
Tequila mule?
What is going on?!
What is a tequila mule?!
[ Sad trombone ]
-A tequila mule?
-I thought gin and tonics.
We drink gin and tonics!
That's what we drink!
You don't like it?
You don't like my --
You don't like
what I do for you?
[ Laughter ]
The beverages we make
and -- and have?
That's not fun for you?
[ Laughter ]
-I think it is fun.
It's just not the most fun.
-Oh, okay, yeah.
What is tequila mule?
What is a mule?
-Tequila mule is --
[ Laughter ]
Tequila is in it, ginger beer,
and lime, and on the rocks.
-Oh, my --
Oh, my God.
All right, stop.
Let's keep playing the game.
What's the next question?
Come on.
Hey, I'm over here, buddy.
Yeah, here we go.
Come on.
I can catch up.
Here we go.
"What is --
What is my safe..."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Your safe word, go.
-Ready?
[ Drumroll ]
What?!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-No, that's -- no!
[ Laughter ]
No, we don't have --
[ Laughing ]
No, that's -- No!
That's not the safe word.
No, I -- Dude, how the heck
did that just happen?
That is so bizarre, dude.
That is so bizarre.
-I don't know --
[ Laughter ]
-Things just got weird, yeah.
No, dude.
[ Laughing ]
What?
How would you --
Why would
we all guess pineapple?
That has nothing --
That is so ridiculous.
That makes me laugh.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
We have a safe word.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
Pineapple, pineapple!
-Pineapple, pineapple.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Sighs loudly ]
[ Breathes deeply, laughs ]
I can't believe it.
"What number am I thinking of
between 1 and 5000?"
-What?
Uh...
♪♪
Oh, I thought
you were giving a hint.
Okay, that's --
Okay.
All right.
-I want this.
[ Laughter ]
-So do I.
[ Drumroll ]
-Let's show our answers.
What do you got?
2,300.
I have 4,297.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I mean --
How did we gue--
How did we guess that?
How did we guess that one?
-You know what, guys?
-I guess we really are
soul mates.
We're best friends.
-I'm done, I'm done.
-Really?
You're done?
-You know what?
Bye.
-Wait, no, Jess!
Jess, come back!
[ Laughs ]
Jess!
Jess, come back!
[ Cheers and applause ]